[Music]
foreign
good morning to you it's been one week
since two massive earthquakes struck
Southern turkey and Northern Syria and
with each passing day the number of
deaths continues to rise
there's been a massive humanitarian
response but very little of the aid sent
to the region has found its way into
Syria where relief efforts have been
hampered by Civil War
or more than 33 000 people are known to
have died in the disaster but that
number is expected to keep Rising as
more victims are retrieved from the
rubble
U.N a humanitarian Chief Martin
Griffiths is set to travel to Syria
after a visit to Turkey he's told Sky
News he'll ask the United Nations
security Council to authorize Aid access
through two more border crossings
meanwhile the international Aid effort
continues to gather Pace here in the UK
donations to the disasters emergency
committee appeal have reached over 60
million pounds
will joining me now is our International
correspondent John Sparks from Caravan
Mirage and John one week on one week on
what's the situation there now
well we have seen the the construction
of these tent cities of popping up uh in
this area in public parks in in plazas
that sort of thing and we just came from
a local hospital as well and they've
turned their reception area into an
accommodation Center as well and you've
got people sleeping in the back of cars
you've got you know people out in the
out sleeping through the night on the
street as well so
I think that suggests very strongly that
the national disaster relief agency is
is struggling to cope with all this and
you have to remember that a lot of the
structures a lot of the apartment blocks
that have been left standing are
unhabitable they have cracks running up
and down the sides people can't go in
and live in the buildings that are many
of the buildings that are still standing
so there's a huge problem it is going to
take a whole lot of money and years and
years to fix all this and we have seen
people expressing their anger on the
streets a lot of people asking questions
that Center on responsibility how did
this happen why did this happen why were
these buildings in such a poor State why
were they unable to stand at the
earthquakes that took um that took place
here it's a sensitive question the
government's trying to get ahead of it
they've issued a series of arrest
warrants 131 so far for building
contractors that promised that there
will be more as well but a big part of
this problem centers on on poor
governance on corruption on the
misallocation of of public funds on a
Failure to observe building codes that
sort of thing and there may be a
political price to pay for the president
reject erdogan who is up for re-election
in June
and meanwhile John a lot of concern
about the the level of Aid that's able
to get into Syria
that's right that is a an entirely uh
different and very very complex problem
really difficult one the um will be at
the the heart of that it will need
International engagement International
involvement and it is urgent we remember
we don't know the scale of the problem
in Syria here journalists have access to
the sites public officials are
accountable to a certain extent for what
is going on it's very difficult to know
what is going on in Syria and the death
toll will almost certainly double the UN
has has suggested that scale of the
problem is very difficult very hard to
get in particularly to Northwest Syria
to deal with this a particularly
difficult problem there
John thanks very much indeed
well in the rubble of the city of
Caravan Mirage Miracles are few and far
between the chances of finding more
survivors growing more unlikely our
correspondent yusufa elberger reports
now and just a warning that some viewers
may find her report distressing
the search for lives has now become a
search to honor the Dead
the United Nations says the current
death toll could be double
and under this Rubble are the bodies yet
to be counted
guarding this
since the earthquake hit
they've retrieved dozens of family
members
14 of them have died including two young
sisters they are now looking for the
Third
now it is very very unlikely that she's
still alive that they want to take the
body so that she can get a proper burial
back in Syria
corpses are being pulled out all around
us
if this one isn't identified it will be
buried in a mass grave just outside of
town
lost in the chaos of This Disaster
family stand watched to ensure their
loved ones don't meet the same fate
they're still pulling our people a full
week on and the air is just full of the
smell of decomposing bodies
Muhammad says they've had to enjoy the
smell while searching
foreign
this is the smell of countless bodies
swelling under the sun on the seventh
day he says
and this is why we honor the Dead with a
burial
after days of digging the buildings no
longer have any form or structure
making the search for victims even
harder
it's an exhausting effort
and one with no end in sight
the site is flattened and the chances of
recovering the body of third sister are
slim Muhammad turns his attention to a
neighboring building where his
three-year-old cousin is still missing
as syrians our return is to our land to
our country to be buried with our family
he says
and so he keeps on looking with the same
dedication no matter if they're dead or
if they're alive
Sky News
so let's take you through the events of
the past week now and the first
earthquake was 7.8 magnitude and it
struck at 4 17 a.m local time last
Monday when most people were asleep nine
hours later it was followed by another
one of 7.5 magnitude
by Tuesday the first International
search and rescue team started arriving
in Turkey including 77 from the UK with
four search Dogs International teams are
still trying to gain entry into Syria
on Wednesday the Turkish president
visited the site of the quake and
announced a three-month state of
emergency in the 10 provinces affected
on Thursday the disaster's emergency
committee launched an appeal to support
Aid and rescue efforts more than 60
million pounds has been raised in just
the past few days
on Friday the UN said more than 5
million people in Syria will need
shelter as a result of the earthquakes
quantifying deaths and injuries there is
difficult due to years of Civil War
on Saturday the un's humanitarian Chief
said that the final death toll from the
earthquakes is likely to exceed 50 000
more than 80 000 have been injured in
Turkey alone
yesterday the Turkish government
targeted more than 130 people allegedly
involved in poor and illegal
construction of buildings in the country
well plenty more reaction to what's
going on there throughout the program in
the meantime though let's fill you in on
some of those other news and the U.S has
shot down another unidentified object in
North America that's the fourth in just
over a week and the third in as many
days it was downed over Lake Huron on
the U.S Canadian border our U.S
correspondent James Matthews has more
now from Washington
this latest object was taken out of the
sky on the instructions of President
Biden it was flying above Lake Huron on
the U.S Canadian border it pulls no
military threat we are told according to
the Pentagon who was octagonal in shape
with strings hanging from it
last night here in the United States the
Department of Defense gave a press
briefing and shed some light on its
thinking it spoke about a heightened
state of alert in the wake of the
Chinese spy balloon and it said that it
had tweaked its radar filters so that it
was picking up smaller objects and it
was more closely scrutinizing the
airspace above the United States I
suppose it will come down to debris
collection and Analysis in terms of
establishing exactly what is being dealt
with but in the meantime the Department
of Defense says it's ruling nothing out
indeed a U.S Air Force General was asked
could we be dealing with
extraterrestrials his answer was I am
ruling nothing out the truth is out
there
so let's take a look then at each of the
flying objects that's been downed over
North America in the past week and on
Saturday the 4th of February on the
instruction of President Joe Biden a U.S
F-22 jet fighter shot down a suspected
Chinese spy balloon off the South
Carolina coast
on Friday President Biden ordered a
fighter jet to shoot down an
unidentified high altitude object off
Northern Alaska the White House said the
object was the size of a small car and
posed a reasonable threat to civilian
Aviation
on Saturday the Canadian Prime Minister
confirmed that a U.S F-22 jet
accompanied by Canadian aircraft shot
down an unidentified object over the
mountainous and sparsely populated
territory of Yukon in the Canadian
Northwest a region which borders America
and then last night a usf-16 jet fired a
missile and downed another unidentified
object over Lake Huron on the U.S Canada
border U.S authorities say the object
flew near sensitive military sites and
could have been used for spying
while following the incidents in North
America here the defense secretary has
announced that the UK will conduct a
review of its own security Ben Wallace
said the UK and her allies will review
what these airspace intrusions mean for
our security this development is another
sign of how the global threat picture is
changing for the worse
now police have arrested two teenagers
following the murder of a 16 year old
girl who was stabbed to death in a
Cheshire Park Brianna Jai from
Warrington was found on a pathway with
serious injuries on Saturday afternoon
Cheshire police say a boy and a girl
both 15 years old had been arrested
after the earlier appeal to trace two
people seen in the park both are from
the local area and remain in custody
officers have urged the public not to
speculate about the details of the
incident
at this moment in time we think this is
an isolated incident and we've got a
large number of detectives working on it
and they will see an increased presence
in the area be that officer searching or
offices on high visibility Patrol that's
just to reassure people and I just asked
don't speculate at this time
now more than 84 000 babies across
England miss out on health visitor
checks within the first two weeks of
life last year that's according to new
government data and the figures have
been highlighted by The National Society
for the Prevention of Cruelty to
Children which says that the checks are
vital for flagging safeguarding concerns
as well as supporting parents as well so
let's get a bit more on this with our
correspondent Becky Cottrell so it
sounds like a large number why is this
happening there well certainly a
shortage in health visitors could be
behind this potentially 5 000 or more
fewer Health visitors in England we know
the NHS is facing a staffing crisis and
it seems this story could be another
example of that and these visits are
vital at the most extreme end for
spotting vulnerable children who need
safeguarding but also just for providing
information to new mums about
breastfeeding or bonding with their
babies the figures for last year are
striking so last year 17 of babies were
not seen within the first two weeks of
their life that is compared to just 12
the year before so more babies not being
seen when they should now the nspcc are
calling for among other things more
funding for health visitors and we do
have a statement from the Department of
Health and Social care they say we are
committed to giving babies and children
the best start in life and have
increased local Public Health Grants
which fund the commissioning of services
including Health visiting to over 3.4
billion for all local authorities we are
also investing around 300 million to
fund a new three-year family hubs and
start for Life program improving health
and education in 75 local authorities
with high levels of deprivation but
clearly the evidence is that too many
babies and new moms are being failed
when it comes to these vital Health
visits okay interesting stuff Becky
thanks very much indeed
to stay with us we've got lots more to
come here on the show in just a moment
I'll be joined by the transport Minister
Richard Holden as laborers accusing the
government of a culture of lavish
spending on taxpayer-funded debit cards
donations to the disaster's emergency
committee earthquake appeal surpass 60
million pounds I'll be speaking with the
chief executive Sally Saeed shortly
and then coming up a little later on in
the hour I'll also be joined by the
chief executive of NHS providers as
nurses prepared to escalate strike
action by involving colleagues from a e
intensive care and cancer Awards
but right now let's take a look at some
of the day's other headlines and tens of
thousands of patients across England are
set to benefit from quicker access to
life-saving tests with 19 additional
Community diagnostic Centers opening
this year more than 90 of the already
operational One-Stop shops have carried
out an additional three million tests
checks and scans since July as the NHS
Works to reduce backlogs
yeah
number of pubs calling at last orders
has risen by more than 200 in a year
analysis by the consultancy group uhy
Haka young shows that the cost of living
crisis has hindered how much people are
willing to spend on a drink while rail
strikes have stopped punters from
traveling to City venues
a fire is broken out on the hillside of
Arthur's seat a spokesperson for
Scottish fire and rescue service has
told Sky News that they were called out
in the late hours of yesterday evening
and were told that one Appliance is
still present at the scene
dozens of flights to and from New
Zealand have been canceled as the
country braces for its second severe
storm in a matter of weeks Cyclone
Gabrielle has already hit the northern
part of New Zealand with Winds of more
than 80 miles an hour and 10 inches of
rain expected in Auckland thousands of
homes have already lost power with some
roads closed in the north of the country
David Jude joliker one of the founding
members of the U.S hip-hop Trio De La
Sol has died at the age of 54. no cause
of death has been given for the rapper
who was no more widely as true guy the
dove in recent years the American rap
artist had said he was battling
congestive heart failure
busy morning this morning lots to ask
the transport Minister Richard Holden
who I'm pleased to say is here with me
good to see you this morning thanks very
much for coming in and let's talk about
the earthquake and the age response
first of all if we can because today
marks of course one week on from this
devastating couple of earthquakes to
strike turkey and Syria
it took four days for aid from the UN to
get into Syria do you agree with the UN
Aid Chief when he said that the
International Community has failed Syria
look I think there's always more we want
to do in these situations in the UK
we've sent out just under 80 Personnel
to help out Specialists search and
rescue personnel and with the
government's matching five million
pounds of donations from the public but
there's always one more we want to do I
think the truth is though the very
difficult situation with countries like
Syria where you've got
um people who are hostile to the UK
they're on the ground and we're doing
what we can to help people hundreds of
aftershocks as well following those two
um major first waves of earthquakes and
I think all of our hearts go out to the
people there who's you know especially
those who are you know still searching
for families buried under collapsed
buildings across Eastern Turkey and of
course we have sanctions against Syria
at the moment the U.S says it's looking
to ease some of those sanctions if it
helps get Aid in and to the people that
need it it will the UK do that I think
we'll be looking at everything we can
when it comes to humanitarian
circumstances we always want to do what
we can to help on the ground I think
that's a sensible thing to do we don't
want to have anything which could go in
and prolong more suffering for people as
well though and you know we have been
out there on the ground doing what we
can to help out with specialist teams
because we have some of these specialist
teams you'll listen all the way back
from uh 2001 when we sent specialist
teams to help out in America as well and
tragically so many of their um First
Responders uh died and and that's a
really good resource that we have and
we're fortunate not to have those issues
here in the UK but no decision on
sanctions no I think we you know all the
government will be looking at all of
these things in the in the round
um but I'm sure it you know we'll be
working lockstep with uh important NATO
Partners like the US on matters like
that I want to turn to to the issue of
spy balloons because the defense
secretary Ben Wallace is saying today
that Britain's going to conduct a
Security review and after the incursion
of these apparent spy balloons over
parts of North America How concerned is
the government I think the government is
is concerned about what's going on we're
concerned about influence more broadly
of some states I mean one of the things
that I think people don't think about
when they think of China is uh is is is
some of these real issues which are
which are there we've taken hundreds of
thousands of people uh well 140 000
people from Hong Kong into the UK last
year alone because of the persecution
they're facing we look at the uyghur
population who are being uh you know who
are being treated absolutely appallingly
in parts of China as well with slave
labor conditions too that China is a
hostile State and we we need to be aware
of that and the way it acts and behaves
um I think there's a there's an era when
China could have gone a different way
and perhaps opened up but it's quite
clear at the moment it's not going in
that direction and we've got to be
really robust in our dealings with China
is it possible that Chinese fire
balloons have already been used over the
UK I mean it's possible you know it's
also possible that and I would think
likely that there will be people from
the Chinese government trying to act as
a hostile State we saw with Russia here
in the UK with the Salisbury poisonings
and other actions that they've taken I
think we've got to be realistic about
the threat that these countries opposed
to the UK they're not interested in our
Democratic Values they're not interested
in standing up for human rights around
the world we are and you know we've got
to keep promoting those values
um at the same time as whenever we can
offer Sanctuary to people from some of
these countries especially we've got a
relation to with reference to Hong Kong
in that context should we be increasing
defense spending the defense secretary
is pushing for an increase in the
defense budget do you back him on that
we've already increased the defense
budget very substantially you know I saw
Ben speaking about this last year where
we're seeing an extra I think it's
around 24 billion pounds over the next
uh 10 years going into defense where the
largest contributors to Nato in Europe
that's all good and obviously you'll
have seen from the last few weeks the
huge amount that we've been leading the
few few weeks almost a year now you know
uh in in the response to Ukraine with
the extra resources we put in there
there's always more I'd like to do when
it's got to be done in the context of a
balanced section of public finances I
want to see as always have a strong
defense and that's also got to we've
also got to have a growing economy which
is which is what pays for all those
public services and also we've got to
have those other public services which
constituents need on the ground as well
let's talk a little bit about out
strikes now because the RCA and the
nursing Union is talking about
escalation of its strike action their
warnings that staff from a e from
intensive care from cancer Awards as
well could be involved in the next round
of strikes also exemptions for some
hospitals May no longer be granted
what's your message to patients who are
waiting for life-saving treatment and
can you say honestly that the government
is doing everything it possibly can to
stop these strikes well from the
transport side we've just had that you
know sad news from yesterday the rmt
aren't you know I I'm going to ballot
their members on a new offer what I want
to see is a settlement that I think
we've been pretty open with a lot of the
unions about that we've got union
members as well as as well as the
representatives employers on these pay
review panels you know we ensured that
last year the well everybody else in the
public sector was facing a pay freeze
nurse has got a an average of three
percent rise and so you know we do
recognize that there's a special case
for nurses and I think some of the way
that they've behaved during the pandemic
as well letting people know to ensure
that Services remain open is really
important to what I want to see as a
settlement here as quickly as possible
but the most important thing we can do
not just for nurses
um but for everybody whether in the
public or private sector is get
inflation down because that will eat
away any pay rise people are seeing at
the moment that's why the government's
committed to halving inflation by the
end of the year because it's a tax on
everybody and whether you're working the
public sector whether you're a you know
a somebody who's retired whether you're
in the private sector and that's that's
got to be our top priority we don't want
to do anything to keep fueling that
inflation because that will just make
the situation worse and we'll always be
chasing our tail okay so that's got to
be the concentration okay well nurses
might say we can't wait for inflation to
come down so too might rail workers as
you say the rmt have rejected what was
described as the best and final offer
from from train companies you as you say
you're a transport minister so where
does that leave talks will you be going
back around the negotiating table well
as I said about inflation you know we've
got a Target to Harvard by the end of
the year so we're not sure we're not
asking people to wait forever we're
really pushing on this as a top priority
but to come to the transport unions the
rmt who have been offered a backdated
pay rise of five percent for last year
compounded with a four percent rise for
this year and all of that pay will be
paid and backdated and that I think is a
pretty generous offer around uh just
over nine percent for the average rail
worker and higher for those on the
lowest incomes as well I think that's a
good deal if the government have really
tried harder my colleagues Hugh maryman
uh has you know and Mark Harper have
worked really hard you know facilitating
these talks between the network rail the
train operating companies and the unions
the unions I think they need to have the
confidence if they still are rejecting
our offer to go to their membership and
say that that's what they want and they
want a fresh ballot they've not done
that and they won't ask their members
for their views the truth is I think a
lot of people who working in the rail
industry now would like to see this
settlement happen they'd like to see the
pay rises in their pay packets you know
that would be a big boost for a lot of
those lower paid Railway workers and I
think that's what I want to see and I
think the union needs have the
confidence to go to its own members and
that's their view quick thoughts on what
labor is highlighting today they're
highlighting uh government spending on
credit cards government issued credit
cards today they say there's a pattern
of using these cards for lavish
entertainment luxury hotel stays is
there a culture of lavish spending in
government departments at the moment
when people are worried about paying
their bills certainly not I mean when I
was on my last visit I was in Lancashire
last week to Berry I stayed in the a
very well appointed Premier Inn and
drove myself up there with some of the
team as well in order to save on costs
and get there in good time all we've
seen is over the last uh 12 years we've
seen a reduction in the 2009 almost a
1000 million pounds was spent on these
cards we're seeing that down to around
150 million pounds last year that's an
85 reduction plus the labor says there's
a 70 increases well I mean you'll have
to ask Angela Reyna when she's on with
you but 2009
995 million pounds spent on these cards
last year by their own figures uh under
around 150 million there's a big
difference there and what I want us to
see is as government spending uh all
properly declared transparently
obviously there'll be some situations
where you know if people are traveling
internationally and it's a big
International Conference there will be
as you know more expenditure on certain
things
um but what we saw in 2012 was all of
this as all of these figures are fully
available on the government website I
checked it out myself and there's a
monthly transparency reporting of this
and transparency is the best thing
sunlight is a great disinfection for
this sort of stuff and so I think that's
why it's so important that we're as
transparent as possible with what the
government spends in word will you ban
these cards I know well I think there's
a use for them and actually if
everything had to be invoiced you know
you can't actually do stuff that you
need to do and can be more expensive and
more bureaucracy what I don't think we
should do is introduce more bureaucracy
as sort of gym hacker style Department
of administrative Affairs to
administrate the other administrators
which seems to be Labor's proposal I
don't want to see more bureaucrats I
want to see transparency coming through
and helping us keep government spending
as reasonable as possible for taxpayers
in my constituency and across the
country okay Richard Holden thanks very
much indeed for coming in today
so let's take a look now what's making
the front pages of some of the mornings
newspapers now and the Daily Telegraph
understands that the ministry of defense
is to conduct a review Into the security
of the UK's own airspace following the
recent incidents elsewhere
according to the final actual times
Taiwanese officials have said that
they're very accustomed to having
Chinese spy balloons enter their
airspace as they have in the U.S and
Canada in recent days
the guardian that carries criticism from
labor over how the government spends its
own in-house expenses allegedly using
taxpayers money on luxury trips and
meals
the time says that supporters of the
former prime minister Liz tras are set
to urge the chancellor to boost growth
through tax cuts
and the mirror says that NHS workers
suffering from long covid face losing
their jobs as ministers cut off their
support
and just to let you know that if you
scan a QR code that you can see on your
screen right now you can listen to
today's scummer news daily podcast with
Neil Patterson and today Neil's looking
at the rise of so-called armchair
detectives following The Disappearance
of Nicola bully and asking if amateur
investigators are hindering the case and
you can subscribe to the Daily wherever
you get your podcasts
now the defense secretary Ben Wallace
has announced that the UK will conduct a
review Into His security after a total
of four unidentified objects were shot
down over North America last week what a
bit earlier in the program I spoke to
the transport Minister Richard Holden
and asked him whether there were any
objects flying over the UK
it's also possible that and I would
think likely that there will be people
from the Chinese government trying to
act as a hostile State we saw with
Russia here in the UK with the Salisbury
poisonings and other actions that
they've taken I think we've got to be
realistic about the threat that these
countries opposed to the UK they're not
interested in our Democratic Values
they're not interested in standing up
for human rights around the world we are
and you know we've got to keep promoting
those values at the same time as
whenever we can offer Sanctuary to
people from some of these countries
especially we've got a relation to with
reference to Hong Kong
well let's bring in our political
correspondent Ali Forte warning to you
Ali you were listening of course to
Richard Holden there and interesting
that he didn't rule out the possibility
that Chinese spy balloons could have
been in action over the UK yeah I mean
this whole story is pretty extraordinary
isn't it he said we need to be realistic
about the threat we know now that this
Security review about these mysterious
objects have been shot down in America
has been launched in this country
effectively looking at what this means
for security here and you you heard him
there he said we've got to be realistic
about the threat China is a hostile
State and we need to be aware of that
there are of course some particularly in
the conservative party I think the Prime
Minister hasn't been tough enough on
Tron China he's been talking about a
systemic challenge there are those that
say he needs to talk about it as a
systemic threat
um but of course all of this kind of
feeds into that and the global
relationships with China and also feeds
in to I think these arguments about the
budgets we have a budget in a month and
there is pressure from the department
for defense for more spending there we
know that inflation has a big impact on
particularly things like Army kit so
they're saying they need more money
we've got you know International Aid in
shop Focus because of what's happening
in Turkey in Syria escalating strike
action if there is any Headroom where is
it going to go so a fascinating budget
in a month and I think all of this ties
into that as well and you talk about
escalating a strike action he's a
transport Minister inevitably I asked
him about that the rail strikes as well
what did we learn from from what he said
about strikes and the possibility of
nurses also escalating their action too
well look I think this is a it is it's a
really dangerous escalation we're
looking at now the nurses are talking
about overnight strikes so longer
strikes involving more people less
exemptions for hospitals a E's staffs
emergency department intensive care
cancer staff that is the sorts of
strikes that are now being talked about
which obviously would have a serious
impact on a lot of people what is the
government going to do we know that both
sides are at loggerheads has been no
sign of a deal so far I thought the most
interesting quote perhaps from Rick
Holden was he said I do recognize there
is a special case for nurses does that
mean that they're going to find a way to
carve out something for nurses without
setting a precedent for the rest of the
public sector you certainly seem to have
a tougher tone when it came and he
obviously is a transport minister to the
rmt and we saw deal collapse at the end
of last week that was called the best
and final offer so will we see
potentially there's definitely a degree
of public sympathy when it comes to
nurses Rising sympathy overall with new
unions from the public will we see a
special case for nurses that remains to
be seen but obviously they want to avoid
what could be the most damaging nurses
strikes yet indeed Ali thanks very much
indeed
now an appeal by UK Charities through
the disaster and emergency committee has
so far raised more than 60 million
pounds fears are growing though about a
second catastrophe well joining me now
is the chief executive for the disasters
emergency committee Saleh Saeed a very
good morning to you thanks so much for
talking to us this morning first of all
can you give us the total sum that's
been raised so far through your appeal
yes an incredible 60 million pounds has
been donated uh mainly from the UK
public all up and down the land and
we're incredibly grateful of course for
that generous amount this was raised
just in three days that's a phenomenal
amount and the money is still coming in
and we hope that more people continue to
give because as you've been reporting
the needs in Northwest Syria and in
Turkey are absolutely huge and uh sadly
ever growing as people now leave the
rubble behind and start to think about
mourning the loss of their friends and
family and rebuilding their lives which
of course will take months and years but
coming back to that figure 60 million
pounds is going to go a long way and
make a huge difference on the ground to
saving and protecting those lives well
yes and I want to ask you a little bit
about where the money does go in a
moment but first have you seen a
reaction quite like this before to one
of your campaigns and are you surprised
at this level of support given that
we're in the middle of a pretty bruising
cost of living crisis
so the disasters of Mercy committee the
dec has been in operation now for over
60 years and just in the last uh year or
so we've run uh three or four appeals
including the Ukraine appeal which is
still ongoing and what's become really
evident now is the testimony to the
generosity of the British public who
once they see a case of such magnitude
such as Syria now and turkey are willing
to give and to support their fellow
humans wherever they may be so it
doesn't surprise me because the
generosity of Republic is now
established and well known for that
we're in greatly grateful
so how will the money be spent what sort
of age relief so immediately where will
it go sure so immediately uh member
Charities the likes of the Red Cross
Islamic relief save the children and
others are already on the ground working
uh with local partners and with staff
and of course with local communities the
priorities have been of course in the
last week uh search and rescue and
there's still hope that people will be
pulled out the rubble but also making
sure that people have the essentials uh
food clean water because this spread of
water-borne diseases is a real concern
uh shelter including a warm blankets
these all absolutely necessary and of
course sadly there are still people that
have not been reached in rural areas
hence why we need to raise as much money
as possible in order to reach even more
people it doesn't give you an example uh
Islamic Leaf one of the dec Charities is
delivering in Northwest Syria medical
supplies to hospitals uh blankets and
mattresses to survivors and also the
grace Red Cross is supporting with a
warm food in in that area so this is the
kind of support that we're currently
providing through our member Charities
and through local Partners but that work
needs to scale up because the needs are
immense
well yes and how concerned are you that
enough Aid will reach people
particularly in Syria where it's so hard
to get access
well of course we are very concerned and
um we're all hoping that more age routes
are opened up from uh turkey into
Northwest Syria and I know the United
Nations are considering a vote on that
soon and that must happen very soon uh
Aid in in Northwest city was always a
challenge because
uh the conflict in Syria is now been
going for 10 years so be even before the
Quake around 90 of the people in that
part of Syria were dependent on
humanitarian Aid and now with this
double tragedy of an earthquake it's
made their their lives on a knife edge
and it's now critical of course that we
scale up that Aid and nothing should
stop the aid access into into the
Northwest Syria and this is what we're
appealing for U.N and governments to
ensure that those Aid corridors are
opened up
and the government has committed Aid to
the region they've also put five million
pounds of money from the government's UK
Aid match into your appeal how important
is the government's contribution
well it's very important of course for
all governments and we're very grateful
to the UK governments for their
contribution to the appeal as you've
rightly said there it's up to five
million pounds which has already been
matched
um but also the UK government has uh
Center military plane to the field
hospital and other assistance but this
has to be a Global Response the scale of
the emergency is huge and it's uh not uh
something that the Turkish government or
the Syrian government or those in
control in Northwest Syria can manage
alone it has to be a Global Response
with the United Nations and everyone
with their own ability trying to
contribute so for those uh listeners and
viewers we would still urge people
please go onto our website
dec.org.uk and contribute whatever you
can your
donations will make a huge difference to
people's lives in turkey and Northwest
Syria well Salas chief executive of the
disasters emergency committee thanks so
much for your time this morning we do
appreciate it
now nurses from a e intensive care and
cancer Awards could soon be joining
colleagues on the picket line as the
Royal College of Nursing prepares to
escalate its dispute with the government
so let's get reaction to that I'm joined
Now by Sir Julian Hartley Who's chief
executive of NHS providers a very good
morning to you and so the nursing Union
threatening to escalate its strike
action what's your response to that
while we're extremely concerned uh uh
you know the the impact of this would be
the most significant yet in terms of uh
impacts on patients already we've seen
around 137
000 appointments and patients
interactions postponed as a consequence
of the strikes given staff uh walking
out in terms of
intensive care emergency departments
Cancer Care this could be the biggest
impact yet and this is at a time of
course when the NHS is driving hard to
really drive down waiting times
following the pandemic we've got an
urgent in emergency care plan as well
and a Workforce plan so at the at the
moment there's a real premium on making
sure we deliver as much activity in
hospitals as possible and and this
action obviously would uh would would
deal a blow to our our progress
what do you say it could have the
greatest impact yet how great would the
risk to patient safety be do you think
well obviously the main focus of trust
leaders is all about protecting patient
safety and we've worked extremely hard
to do that in collaboration with the RCN
and other staff side uh Union colleagues
um we would be though in terms of this
proposal certainly in terms of risk to
patients would be elevated and we'd need
to think really hard about how we'd
manage and mitigate those risks given
they are in those key areas so the whole
process that we've been working through
previously in terms of local
negotiations around derogations around
staff at work and so on I think we need
to know more from the RCN about exactly
how they propose that that will work
because our priority is to make sure we
protect uh patient safety at all times
meanwhile strikes in Wales are on hold
after offers of a seven percent pay
increase nurses in Scotland who are
members of the RCN and the GMB unions
aren't holding strikes while
negotiations take place there what would
you like to see happen in England
well I think it's clear that we would
want to see negotiations
um between the government and the RCN on
this as soon as possible because you
know every day we have more strike
action is a day lost in terms of patient
uh interactions and indeed reducing
those waiting times we really need the
government to sit down with uh nurses to
make sure that we can bring these uh um
walkouts to to a speedy conclusion as I
say we are at a key point in terms of
NHS recovery we don't want to see this
continue we do want to see a resolution
it's the in the interests of patients to
see this brought us with conclusion and
I would urge the government to open
negotiations as soon as possible
well yes the Department of Health has
indicated that there's no change to its
position for nurses in England including
on pay for the current year which is one
of the main contentions in this dispute
what do you make of that position well
obviously I think it's important that
all parties sit down and negotiate I
think that we've seen as you've said
what's happened in other parts of the UK
we need to to work on the art of the
possible we need to be pragmatic we need
to see the government take the first
step to engage productively you know to
look at what is doable in the context of
this dispute because the longer this
goes on the harder it gets to deliver
against the priorities we've set for the
NHS and the amount of work and
disruption and the challenges that go
into handling and mitigating every
strike day are really really significant
for for us at a time when we need to be
focusing on the priorities about
delivering for patients in Urgent Care
making sure we're treating patients on
the the the the backlog uh waiting for
operations and and delivering for
patients overall
meanwhile Junior doctors are balloting
for strike action How concerned are you
about that what impact do you think that
could have if they do uh walk out well
of course that again is a major worry
for trusts a combination of Junior
doctors nurses ambulances you know this
really is getting into serious territory
uh Uncharted Territory actually in terms
of the uh level of industrial action and
we really really don't want to see that
happen which I think makes it all the
more important that we find a resolution
to the current impasse the NHS is at a
key point in terms of what it's aiming
to deliver for patients and therefore we
want to make sure that all of the
considerations around strike action all
of the issues are are put around the
table people come together and make sure
we see a resolution to this we can't
afford to go on in this way when we've
got so much work to do so many
priorities to attend to for patients
that use the NHS
some sympathy for the nurses
well trust leaders of course
um have a
a huge level of understanding for where
the nurses are you know I've worked with
magnificent nurses in my career during
the NHS they're fantastic colleagues
they have experienced significant
pressures of late and the cost of living
crisis obviously is impacting hard so of
course there's a high level of
understanding from from trust leaders in
relation to the the brilliant nurses
that work in in in hospitals Community
Services mental health trusts across the
whole of the country which is why we
want to see this resolution brought to a
conclusion as quickly as possible
well it's Julian Hartley we appreciate
your time this morning thanks very much
indeed for talking to us